- I have a dream,
that one day this nation will rise up
and live out the true
meaning of its creed.
♪ Love set me free ♪
- I have a dream that one day
people will treat immigrants
the same way that they
treat everyone else.
- I have a dream that in the future
anyone with an accent just like mine
would be able to speak up
and their voices would be
as heard as anyone else's.
- I have a dream that
little black-skinned boys
and little dark-skinned girls
will grow up loving their skin color.
- I have a dream that I will see
people that look like me
more represented in tech and
in the engineering field.
- I have a dream that one day
more South Asians will defy convention
to follow their passions
because you don't need to be
a lawyer, doctor, or
engineer to be successful.
- I have a dream that after
our first female president,
we'll have our first gay president.
- I have a dream that one day
we'll live in a society
where last names like Pena and Hussein
will have the same stature
as Bush and Clinton.
- I have a dream that in the future
women, no matter where they're from,
how much money they make,
will have complete access
to reproductive health care.
Simple as that.
- I have a dream that no child
will ever have to grow
up without a family.
- I have a dream that one day
systemic racism is just eliminated.
One day, right?
♪ Love set me free ♪
(uplifting music)
- We will be able to speed up that day
when all of God's children,
black men and white
men, Jews and Gentiles,
Protestants and Catholics,
will be able to join hands
and sing in the words of
the old Negro spiritual,
"Free at last, free at last.
"Thank God almighty, we are free at last."
(crowd cheering wildly)
- [Man] All right, all
right, let's go now.
Let's go.
And keep order, keep order.
(crowd cheering)
(whooshing)
(metal creaking)